[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers hallo
und guten Abend ihnen allen während die
Weltklimakonferenz startet sendet unser
Planet ein Notsignal das sagt der
UNO-Generalsekretär heute das Notsignal
ist laut und deutlich es betrifft
bereits jetzt aber Millionen von
Menschen aber Millionen von Leben es
verursacht aber Milliarden an Kosten die
Frage ist dennoch ob wir es hören und
danach handeln an mangelndem Aufwand
kann es nicht liegen 40.000 Teilnehmer
110 Regierungschefs vor Ort fast zwei
Wochen Dauer die Weltgemeinschaft hat
sich versammelt aber ob diese neueste
Klimakonferenz am Ende wirklich ein
Fortschritt bringt ist alles andere als
sicher dabei fangen die Probleme direkt
am Konferenzort an aus Ägypten berichtet
gollinea Thai
Ägyptens erste Front gegen den
Klimawandel ist hier am Mittelmeer wo
riesige Betonklötze ins Wasser versickt
werden die Ingenieurin also Abdelhamid
begutachtet die mittlerweile 22 km lange
Mauer der Wellenbrecher ja für ja wird
sie länger ohne sie würden die
Wahrzeichen von Alexandria überflutet
werden von mittlerweile drei Meter hohen
Wellen
wir kämpfen gegen die Zeit wir müssen
sehr schnell sein um uns gegen den
Klimawandel zu wappnen wir alle fühlen
ihn jetzt gerade seit den letzten zehn
Jahren
noch nie erlebte ihre Stadt in so kurzen
Abständen so starke Stürme so hohe Welle
Alexandria zählt zu den am meisten durch
den Klimawandel gefährdeten Städten der
Welt
genau wie weite südlich des Nil Delta
eine der fruchtbarsten und dicht
besiedelsten Flächen der Erde der
Brotkorb Ägyptens
Mohammed alan ist einer von Millionen
Kleinbauern im Delta erlebt von
Zuckerrohr Gemüse Reis und Weizen immer
häufiger erlebt er wie seine Pflanzen
ihre Form und Farbe verändern
was für gewöhnlich drei Monate zum
Reifen brauchte das braucht jetzt länger
die Pflanzen können aus der Erde nichts
mehr aufnehmen am Ende leidet die Ernte
darunter sie fällt schlecht aus
tote Palmen an einigen Stellen im Delta
ist die Erde bleich fast so sandig wie
am Strand sie erstickt dann immer mehr
Salz das durch die Überflutungen der
Küstenregion übrig bleibt und ins
Grundwasser getrieben wird
die Mango ist die wohl berühmteste
Frucht Ägyptens aber den mangobauern im
Nil Delta setzen die immer extremeren
wetterumschwimmer zu vergangenes Jahr
wurde fast die gesamte Ernte dadurch
vernichtet
das Wetter verändert sich jetzt zu
schnell es ist nicht stabil wie früher
du kommst aus dem Winter und bist im
Sommer du kommst aus dem Sommer und zack
bist du im Winter für die Mango ist das
ziemlich schlecht
der Nil ist die Lebensader des Landes
seit jeher
95% der Bevölkerung leben neben ihm auf
nur 5,5% der Fläche Ägyptens
der große renaissancestaudamm Strom
aufwärts in Äthiopien Afrikas größter
Damm ist kurz vor der Fertigstellung er
wird ebenso wie die durch den
Klimawandel verursachten Hitzewellen die
Wassermenge der Nachbarn am Nil
drastisch reduzieren und Ägyptens
Lebensader bedrohen
und es ist ja nicht alleine Ägypten
pünktlich zur Konferenz neue Daten von
der Welt wetterorganisation der UNO die
vergangenen acht Jahre sind auf dem
schlechten Weg dahin die global bisher
heißesten überhaupt zu sein vor allem
durch extreme dürren fehlt bis zu 19
Millionen Menschen im Osten Afrikas der
Zugang zu Nahrung die Gletscher
schmelzen schneller als zuvor der
Anstieg des Meeresspiegels hat sich seit
1993 verdoppelt die Konzentration der
wichtigsten Treibhausgase ist auf einem
neuen Höchststand das sind die Fakten
das wäre Anlass zu handeln und dennoch
steht diese Weltklimakonferenz wie kaum
eine vor ihr vor der entscheidenden
Frage ist sie noch Chance oder schon
Farce Elisa Miebach berichtet
sie haben sich auf den Weg gemacht die
deutschen Fridays for future Aktivisten
auf dem Landweg über den Balkan bis
Istanbul dann mit dem Flugzeug weiter
nach Ägypten sie fahren obwohl eine der
bekanntesten klimaaktivistinnen Greta
thienberg die Konferenz beikottiert wir
sind dort um den Politikerinnen
Politikern auf die auf die Finger zu
schauen wenn sie dort verhandeln dass
der Raum der da geöffnet wird wo darüber
geredet wird und wir glauben dass es
ganz wichtig ist dass wir dort sind vor
Ort sind präsent sind die Klimagipfel
mit Sponsoren wie in diesem Jahr etwa
Coca-Cola sei nur Greenwashing so
teambacks Vorwurf ein Blick auf den
Treibhausgasausstoß zeigt tatsächlich
konnten die Konferenzen die Emissionen
bisher nicht senken und doch dass sich
die rund 200 Länder der Erde überhaupt
darauf geeinigt haben die Erderwärmung
auf 1,5 Grad beschränken zu wollen sehen
viele hier als Meilenstein die
Klimagipfel lenken jedes Jahr den Blick
der Welt auf die Krise die besonders die
ärmsten Länder mit Wucht trifft das ist
das einzige Forum wo die verletzlichen
Staaten dieser Welt eine Stimme haben
und das dürfen wir Ihnen nicht wegnehmen
oder entwerten aber wir brauchen
gleichzeitig den Druck von außen da
drauf dass deutlich mehr passiert als
bisher passiert ist auch durch diesen
Druck kommt am ersten Tag ein neues
Thema auf die Agenda zum ersten Mal
haben die Staaten sich bereit erklärt
offiziell über finanzielle Hilfen für
Klimaschäden zu verhandeln vor allem die
reichen Länder haben durch ihre
Emissionen die Schäden des Klimawandels
verursacht die Ärmsten tragen die Kosten
aber meist noch allein wir müssen das
klare Signal an die Entwicklungsländer
senden
diejenigen die besonders vom Klimawandel
betroffen sind dass wir uns auf den Weg
machen Schäden und Verluste praktisch
pragmatisch auszugleichen und das müssen
wir verbinden dass alle Staaten sich
noch einmal dazu bekennen und noch mehr
machen um beim Klimaschutz selbst wieder
auf 1,5 Grad Kurs zu kommen bisher
reichen die Ziele der Länder nicht um
das 1,5 Grad Ziel zu erreichen
das kritisieren neben der Wissenschaft
auch die deutschen Aktivisten die
mittlerweile in Sharm el Sheikh
angekommen sind trotzdem glauben sie
noch an den Prozess ich finde es ganz
entscheidend dass diese Klimakonferenz
trotzdem stattfindet in der Zeit wo wir
so viele Kriege und Krisen in der Welt
haben die Klimakrise betrifft den ganzen
Planeten das heißt wir müssen aus allen
möglichen Ländern zusammenkommen und
versuchen an gemeinsamen Weg wie wir
hier weitergehen wollen zu finden und
genau deshalb sind sie hier sie sehen
die Klimakonferenzen als Bühne auf der
sich die Länder vor der ganzen Welt für
ihre Klimapolitik rechtfertigen müssen
einer der Wirtschaft und Klimaschutz
zusammen denkt als Direktor einer der
renommiertesten Institutionen dazu ist
Ottmar Edenhofer vom Potsdam Institut
für Klimafolgen Forschung Herr Professor
schon guten Abend guten Abend das große
Ziel war und ist und sollte sein
Erderwärmung bei 1,5 Grad stoppen kann
das diese Konferenz überhaupt noch
erreichen nein das kann diese Konferenz
nicht erreichen denn das was die Staaten
bisher auf den Tisch gelegt haben ist zu
wenig und das was sie auf dem Tisch
gelegt haben haben sie bisher nicht
umgesetzt wir sind weit von einem 1,5
Grad Pfad entfernt und wir müssen jetzt
darauf achten dass wir um jedes Zehntel
Grad kämpfen aber diese Konferenz wird
diesen Durchbruch nicht bringen welchen
Wert hat er dann das Pariser Abkommen in
dem dieses 1,5 Grad Ziel ja explizit
drin steht überhaupt noch
das hat den Wert dass sich die gesamte
Staatengemeinschaft danach ausrichtet
aber es gibt natürlich auch eine
Schwäche dieser Konferenz dass es eben
keine verbindlichen Verpflichtungen gibt
und dass die Staaten eben wenn Sie diese
Verpflichtungen nicht erfüllen mit
keinerlei Sanktionen rechnen müssen und
das kann auch so nicht weitergehen
auf welchem Weg sind wir denn jetzt was
ist denn das neue Ziel wenn 1,5 Grad
nicht mehr funktioniert naja es gibt ja
Berechnungen die sagen wenn alle Staaten
ihre freiwilligen Selbstverpflichtungen
einhalten würden dann wären wir so auf
einem
2,52,8 Grad Pfad aber in der Tat ist es
ja so dass 2021 die weltweiten
Emissionen wieder einen historischen
Höchststand erreicht haben und wir durch
den Ukraine Krieg auch erleben dass es
einen massiven eine massive Rückkehr der
fossilen Energieträger gibt vor allem
Kohle aber auch Gas und Öl und hier ist
aus meiner Sicht eine unbedingte
Voraussetzung dass zu dieser Konferenz
in Ägypten jetzt die Haupt Emittenten
sich endlich zusammensetzen und Wege
finden wie sie jetzt die Emissionen
tatsächlich und effektiv reduzieren
können die Haupte mit Händen also etwa
die aus Indien und China sind gar nicht
dabei
naja also die Haupt Emittenten das sind
die USA das ist die Europäische Union
das ist China und Indien die verhandeln
natürlich hier mit aber es ist trotzdem
so dass aus meiner Sicht jetzt im Rahmen
von G20 oder G7 ein Forum gefunden
werden muss in dem die großen Konflikte
auf den internationalen fossilen
ressourcenmärkten ausgetragen werden
können und ich glaube man kann das von
dieser Konferenz nicht erwarten diese
Konferenz ist eine Konferenz für die
Schwellen und Entwicklungsländer und die
kämpfen dafür dass Ihre Klimaschäden
kompensiert werden dass es richtig aber
wir brauchen weitere und effektivere
Schritte Herr Professor wir haben ja
allgemein auch bei anderen Problemen
aktuell in der Welt eher das Gefühl das
ist da kein gemeinsames nach vorne mehr
gibt sondern eher ein gespaltenes zurück
gerade die USA und China finden ja keine
Basis wie sehen Sie denn die jetzt
ausgerechnet beim Klimaschutz dass man
die neu aufbauen kann
das ist zunächst mal die gemeinsame
Betroffenheit auch China wird vom
Klimawandel schon vor 2030 stark
betroffen sein das trifft auch auf
Indien zu und auch Russland denken wir
etwa an das Auftauen des permafrosses
ist vom Klimawandel betroffen also es
gibt über die Klimaschäden die in den
nächsten zehn Jahren stärker werden eine
Gemeinsamkeit und es gibt natürlich auch
massive Konflikte und die internationale
Kooperation ist nicht einfacher geworden
durch den ukrainekrieg dennoch müssen
wir jetzt versuchen in begrenzten
Bereichen eine solche Kooperation
zustande zu bringen und ganz
aussichtslos ist das nicht was muss denn
Deutschlands Rolle bei alledem jetzt
sein sind wir noch Vorreiter denn auch
Deutschland holt ja gerade die Kohle
wieder raus naja also ich glaube
kurzfristig hat Deutschland sicherlich
recht dass wir flexibel sein müssen was
den Einsatz von Kohle Gas und auch der
Verlängerung bei der Verlängerung der
Laufzeiten der Kernenergie das ist im
Kern richtig das muss eben später
kompensiert werden aber ich glaube die
Rolle Deutschlands muss sein dass
Deutschland jetzt gerade in Sharm el
Sheikh dafür sorgt dass eine Plattform
geschaffen wird für mehr Kooperation zum
Beispiel das bilaterale Abkommen
geschlossen werden zum Kohleausstieg und
das die multilateralen
Entwicklungsbanken vor allem auch in
Vietnam in Indonesien den Kohleausstieg
mit finanzieren jetzt gibt es ja wir
haben es gerade im kurzen Beitrag auch
gesehen auch Kritiker die sagen so eine
Konferenz ist möglicherweise sogar
gefährlich Stichwort Greenwashing also
sprich man tut so als würde man was tun
welchen Sinn macht aus ihrer Sicht diese
Konferenz insgesamt überhaupt noch also
die Konferenz ist sinnvoll weil es ein
Forum ist das Multilateralismus in die
Stadt miteinander reden aber man darf
diese Konferenz nicht überfrachten und
wir sollten jetzt auch nicht jedes Mal
bei dieser Konferenz sagen steht der
große Durchbruch bevor der steht jetzt
nicht bevor sondern wir müssen uns jetzt
wirklich darum bemühen dass sich die
Haupt-
zu finden wie sie jetzt den Einstieg in
die Emissionsreduktion finden und das
ist dringend und das ist wichtig bei
Kohle Öl und Gas und ich denke das ist
das was jetzt als Herausforderung
ansteht also diese Konferenz habe ich
Sie richtig verstanden nicht die ganze
Zeit darauf abklopfen was jetzt
rauskommt was müsste am Ende aber
trotzdem stehen damit sie sagen würden
das war jetzt kein komplettes scheitern
also ich glaube dass jetzt auf der
Tagesordnung über die Klimaschäden
verhandelt wird und das darüber
verhandelt wird wie man etwa einen
versicherungsschirm vor allem für die
schwellen- und Entwicklungsländer
einrichten kann das ist gut ich finde es
auch gut wenn bekräftigt werden würde
dass man aus der Kohle aussteigen will
es wäre auch sicherlich gut wenn mit
Südafrika Vietnam und den kleineren
Staaten die es jetzt auf Kohle setzen
solche Abkommen geschlossen werden
würden aber wichtig wäre für mich dann
dennoch dass in anderen Foren G20 G7
diese großen Konflikte auf den
internationalen Ressourcen angepackt
werden ein Kollege von ihnen ein
Schweizer Klimaforscher der hat gesagt
die vier größten Umweltprobleme sind der
Mensch ist dumm faul egoistisch und
kurzsichtig brauchen wir am Ende eine
Therapiesitzung mit uns selbst
also Therapiesitzung mit uns selbst sind
immer gut aber ich glaube wir sollten
eigentlich sagen optimismus ist etwas
für schlecht informierte Leute aber wir
sollten die Hoffnung nicht aufgeben
nämlich die Hoffnung dass sich Menschen
auch manchmal auf das gute und richtige
ausrichten können sagt Professor Otmar
Edenhofer vom Potsdam Institut für
Klimafolgen Forschung Herr Professor
herzlichen Dank für ihre Expertise heute
Abend wieder ich danke Ihnen
in Deutschlands fünftgrößter Stadt haben
die Menschen ihren Oberbürgermeister
abgewählt das war nicht so einfach
obwohl selbst seine eigene Partei dafür
war dass er geht nur er selbst sah das
ganz anders
nach Korruptionsvorwürfen und einer
langen Liste von Fehltritten haben die
Frankfurter offenbar genug von ihrem
Oberbürgermeister Peter Feldmann muss
gehen in einem Bürgerentscheid stimmte
eine überwältigende Mehrheit von rund 95
Prozent für seine Abwahl er wolle sich
aber weiter engagieren erklärte der
SPD-Politiker am Abend was alle Parteien
auch die SPD hatten Feldmanns Rücktritt
gefordert das hatte er bis zuletzt
abgelehnt und eine Abwahl durch die
Stadtverordneten nicht angenommen seit
Oktober steht der 64-Jährige wegen des
Vorwurfs der vorteilsname vor Gericht
nach tagelangem warten auf See hat
Italien zwei privaten rettungsschiffen
die Erlaubnis erteilt den Hafen von
Catania anzufahren mehr als 140 Personen
verließen das deutsche Rettungsschiff
humanity one aber nur Minderjährige und
Kranke durften von Bord mehr als 30
Menschen mussten bleiben auf der
geobarems mit mehr als 570 geflüchteten
wird aktuell geprüft wer das Schiff
verlassen darf die neue italienische
Regierung fordert dass sich die Staaten
um die geflüchteten kümmern unter deren
Flagge die privaten Rettungsschiffe
fahren
hier ist Bürgermeister klitschko hat die
Bevölkerung in der ukrainischen
Hauptstadt dazu aufgerufen für den Fall
eines Zusammenbruchs der Wärmestrom und
Wasserversorgung Vorkehrungen zu treffen
er forderte die Menschen auf Vorräte
anzulegen und im Notfall zeitweise die
Stadt zu verlassen nach den russischen
Angriffen auf die Energieinfrastruktur
haben ganze Stadtteile stundenweise
keinen Strom
bei Angriffen auf mehrere
Flüchtlingscamps im Norden Syriens sind
mindestens zehn Menschen getötet und
über 70 verletzt worden das Berichten
der Opposition nahestehende Beobachter
und Rettungskräfte demnach hätten
Regierungstruppen Lager im
Rebellengebiet rund um Idlib beschossen
zum Teil mit international geächteter
Streumunition auch syrische und
russische Kampfflugzeuge sollen an den
Angriffen beteiligt gewesen sein
im Wahlkampfendspurt zwei Tage vor der
US vor den us-zwischenwahlen haben
Demokraten und Republikaner auf ihre
Ex-Präsidenten gesetzt im wichtigen
swing-state pencilvania trat Präsident
beiden gemeinsam mit Barack Obama auf
der erklärte es gehe um nicht weniger
als die Demokratie selbst bei der Wahl
könnten die Demokraten ihre Mehrheit im
Kongress verlieren für die Republikaner
rührte Donald Trump noch einmal die
Werbetrommel er rief dazu auf den Zitat
radikalen Linken einen Denkzettel zu
verpassen
ja und der Mann selbst will
möglicherweise auch noch mal zurück ins
Weiße Haus er macht ja seit Monaten
daraus ein Trump typisches Ratespiel
jetzt deutet er an in einer Zitat sehr
sehr sehr kurzen Zeit würden seine Fans
so glücklich sein der Trump Sound ist
wieder da mit voller Kraft die
Zwischenwahlen könnten den USA einen
deutlichen Rechtsruck bescheren und auch
auf der anderen Seite des Atlantiks bei
uns in Europa ist dieser Trend zu
beobachten rechte Parteien werden
deutlich präsenter Nationalisten haben
Erfolg und das Gemeinschaftsprojekt EU
sieht dabei zunehmend hilflos aus wie
Julia rech und ultra aus Brüssel zeigen
der Schriftsteller kurt tucholski war
ein Warner vor 90 Jahren verfasst er das
Gedicht Europa es beschreibt den
Untergang des Kontinents im nationalen
warnt seine Worte klingen dramatisch
aktuell
Farnen und Hymnen an allen Ecken Europa
soll doch verrecken
die italienische Regierungschefin Meloni
hat gerade einen Wahlkampf gegen Europa
und für Italien geführt und nun rollt
Brüssel ihr den roten Teppich aus Meloni
und ihre Partei haben ihre Wurzeln in
Italiens faschistischer Vergangenheit
nun bezeichnet sie sich selbst als
nationalkonservativ
Brüssel verdrängt das Wohl und auch
meloni-sätze aus dem Wahlkampf
in Europa fragen Sie jetzt alle was wird
die Meloni machen ganz einfach der Spaß
ist vorbei Italien verteidigt wieder
seine nationalen Interessen
melonisiek ist ein weiterer Triumph für
die Nationalisten die ein anderes Europa
wollen so wie Polens Regierungschef
moraviewski er schwärmt vom Christentum
als Leitkultur in Europa sowie die
französische rechtsextreme die ein
Europa mit hochgezogenen Grenzen will in
der die Nationalisten das Sagen haben
sowie Ungarns Regierungschef Orban der
die Unabhängigkeit der Gerichte
abschafft der Angriff auf die Demokratie
wird nicht nur von außen geführt uns
versucht zu destabilisieren sondern
natürlich auch von innen das macht mehr
sehr viel Sorge dass nicht nur
Nationalisten sondern rechtsextreme
Autokraten in Europa auf dem Vormarsch
sind
Victor Orban schafft Stück für Stück
autoritäre Strukturen in seinem Land
deshalb läuft ein rechtsstaatsverfahren
in der EU gegen ihn die anderen
Nationalisten könnten ihn schützen das
zum Beispiel bei den jetzt gegen gegen
Ungarn dass sie das einfach blockieren
und dass die EU alle Werkzeuge verliert
das Recht noch durchzusetzen
Europa erlebt eine Zeitenwende
Arbeitslosigkeit Firmenpleiten Inflation
Angst vor sozialen Unruhen Beobachter
erinnert das an die dunkelsten Zeiten
des Kontinents
wir müssen glaube ich anerkennen dass
die die Situation so fragil ist so
instabil ist das alles passieren kann
und niemand hätte wahrscheinlich in der
zur Mitte der 20er Jahre des letzten
Jahrhunderts gedacht dass eine eine
große Katastrophe des ganzen Kontinents
unmittelbar bevorsteht
Kurt Tucholskys Gedicht von 1932 endet
mit diesen Worten die Nation ist das
achte Sakrament gott segne diesen
Kontinent eine Mahnung auf die damals
niemand hörte
und jetzt gucken wir noch mal auf
weitere Nachrichten von diesem Sonntag
wieder mit Diana die Ratsvorsitzende der
Evangelischen Kirche in Deutschland
Kurschus sieht bei der Prävention und
Aufarbeitung sexueller Gewalt weiter
Handlungsbedarf zum Auftakt der Synode
in Magdeburg sagte sie Verantwortlichen
viele teilweise der Mut konsequent zu
handeln manche Betroffene machten die
Erfahrungen dass ihnen nicht geglaubt
werde bei der Debatte um deutsche
Waffenlieferungen an die Ukraine wurde
keine Einigkeit erzielt Befürworter und
Gegner blieben bei ihren Positionen
in der Fußball-Bundesliga gab es heute
zwei Begegnungen Bayer Leverkusen siegte
mit 5 zu 0 gegen Union Berlin wodurch
die Berliner ihre Tabellenführung
verloren haben der SC Freiburg spielte
gegen den ersten fC Köln entstand zwei
zu null
bei den touren-weltmeisterschaften in
Liverpool hat Lucas Dauser am Barren
Silber geholt es ist die erste
WM-Medaille für den 29-Jährigen und die
einzige für das deutsche Team bei dieser
Weltmeisterschaft nach einem souveränen
Auftritt musste sich Dauser lediglich
den Chinesen jinj geschlagen geben
als 2016 der Literatur Nobelpreis an Bob
Dylan ging da dachten manche erstmal an
einer peinliche Verwechslung war es
natürlich nicht es war die Würdigung für
die ungeheure poetische Kraft die in
dillens Songs liegt der Mann kann
schreiben nicht nur Lieder es gibt jetzt
ein Buch von ihm indem er nicht auf die
größten Dillons Hits zurückblickt
sondern auf die Musik die ihm geprägt
hat dank Claudio Armbruster können wir
das jetzt miterleben und dabei einiges
erfahren über uns und unsere Welt
[Musik]
von Zeit zu Zeit hören wir den alten
gern doch diesmal geht es nicht um seine
gesungene Lyrik sondern um seine Prosa
an um sein neues Buch mit dem
unverschämt hochtrabenden Titel die
Philosophie des modernen Songs drunter
macht er es nicht man ist ja
Literaturnobelpreisträger
in diesem Buch also beschreibt Dylan
seine Lieblingslieder nein er beschreibt
sie nicht er liebt Kursziel mit Worten
die Lieder der anderen Frank Sinatra
stranger
Alien vorher the
mattering
is self interest
[Musik]
66 Lieder hat er ausgesucht von
berühmten und von vergessenen
Songwritern Dillons literarisches
Mixtape seit vielen Jahren schon arbeite
er daran heißt es Analysen Gefühle
interessantes und unnützes Wissen die
musikwissenschaftliche Doktorarbeit von
Bob Dylan
hier ein kurzes Zitat aus seinem Text
über den großen Song Black Magic woman
man kann weiterhin aus der Musik eine
Wissenschaft machen wollen aber in der
Wissenschaft wird eins und eins immer
zwei ergeben Musik dagegen erklärt uns
wie alle Kunst auch die Kunst der Liebe
das 1 + 1 unter optimalen Bedingungen 3
ist
warum hat er dieses Buch geschrieben
keine Antwort kein Interview wie immer
lassen wir ihn zum Schluss doch einfach
noch mal lesen weil es so schön ist
[Musik]
und dann diese Stimme unsterblich schon
jetzt Bob Dylan für viele der beste
Songwriter aller Zeiten
zurück ins Tagesgeschäft mit Blick auf
die Woche die uns erwartet Ulrike
[Musik]
in den Unternehmen die Rechte von
Arbeitnehmern und Arbeitnehmerinnen
geregelt sind diese im
Betriebsverfassungsgesetz das am Montag
seinen 70-jähriges Jubiläum feiert in
Berlin werden die gb-präsidentin Jasmin
fahimi und Bundeskanzler Scholz an dem
Festakt teilnehmen
auch wenn Präsident beiden am Dienstag
bei den US-Kongresswahlen nicht auf dem
Stimmzettel steht so ist diese Wahl auch
ein Stimmungstest für ihn verliert seine
Partei ihre knappe Mehrheit im Kongress
hätten es die Demokraten noch schwerer
ihre Gesetzesvorhaben umzusetzen
am Donnerstag wird der Bundestag über
das sogenannte triaschgesetz abstimmen
es soll Regeln welcher Patient eine
intensivmedizinische Behandlung erhält
wenn zu wenig Betten da sind das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hatte vom
Gesetzgeber eine Regelung gefordert
bisher haben Ärzte die Entscheidung
getroffen
wer fährt mit zur WM nach Katar das wird
Bundestrainer Hansi Flick am Donnerstag
verkünden die WM beginnt in zwei Wochen
die Kritik an dem umstrittenen Gastgeber
reißt nicht ab dem Land werden massive
Menschenrechtsverletzungen vorgeworfen
und jetzt noch ein weiterer Ausblick und
zwar aufs Wetter morgen im Osten und
Süden größere sonnige Abschnitte sonst
oft bewölkt und gelegentlich etwas Regen
bei lebhaften Südwestwind 11 bis 18 Grad
in den nächsten Tagen leicht wechselhaft
aber auch etwas Sonne Dienstag sehr mild
mit 11 bis 19 Grad danach allmählich
Kühler
es war unsere Welt an diesem Sonntag im
heute-journal wir alle hier im Team
sagen Danke für ihr Interesse morgen
freuen sich an dieser Stelle eine
galinek und eins Wolf und gegen 0 Uhr 25
gibt es die nächsten Nachrichten heute
Express mit Maja Weber von uns allen
Ihnen einen angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]